[موسيقى]
طواقم الانقاذ تبحث
عن عالقين تحت
ركام
منزل عائله ابو بدر وال الحواجري
و
عائله
[موسيقى]
النجار دفاع المدني في حد سامعني هان عندك
تحت السقف كم واحد
مروان اي سقف اي سقف عندك هذا شايف
كيف عندك صغار وثنتين كبار في هذه المنطقه
اه اه اح طلعنا واحد من دمار كبير في
المنازل المستهدفه في منطقه
الزوايده طلعتوا حدا من ه طلع اه طلعوا
طلعوا كذا شهيد من ه الاله اه
[موسيقى]
في اسمع دي بالك يتحدث راس احد ضباط جهاز
الدفاع المدني بان من ه بدون راس هنا
اشلاء لشهداء يعني قطع من اللحم لشهداء في
هذا
المكان دير
بالال ليشش اشلا
وين خذ هي بطانيه البطانيه
مبر
شوبر خذ ه
كبرتايه طواقم الدفاع المدني وفرق
الانقاذ يعني تعثر على اشلاء الشهداء وقطع
لحم صغيره للشهداء حيث
قطعت صواريخ الاحتلال اجساد الاطفال
والنساء الى اشلا عدد من المفقودين
لازالوا تحت ركام المنازل التي دمرت بفعل
القصف من المقاتلات الحربيه ل
هذه المنازل في منطقه الزويده وسط قطاع
غزه قطع من اللحم اشلاء
شهداء تم العثور
عليها من فرق الانقاذ
والطواقم الطبيه طواقم الاسعاف في جهاز
الدفاع
المدني يعني هذا ما تبقى من اشلاء
الشهداء اشلاء شهداء في منزل عائله ابو
بدر وعائله النجار عائله الحواجري في
منطقه
الزوايده فرق
الانقاض تعمل على البحث عن مفقودين تحت
ركام هذه المنازل التي دمرتها المقاتلات
الحربيه مر كبير خلفته مقاتلات الاحتلال
الحربيه بعد استهدافها لعدد من منازل
المواطنين في منطقه الزوايده تحديدا منطقه
التعابين انتشال
اشلاء
للشهداء عدد من العالقين لازالوا تحت هذا
الركاب بحاجه الى معدات ثقيله لانتشال من
تحت ركام المنازل
المدمره سداف منزل يعود لعائله النجار في
منطقه
الزوايده وسط قطع
[موسيقى]
غز
عدد من
العالقين تحت ركام منزل عائله النجار في
منطقه الزوايده وسط قطع
غزه منزل عائله
بدر والنجار وكذلك
الحواجري في منطقه
الزوا حج البيت مقله من
السكان البيت في سكان و كان اه وفي نازحين
في نازحين ك نعم يعني ما زال في ناس تحت
الركام وربما ربما في تحت الطابق التحتاني
اذا في حد ينط لان تحت ماضن تطلع حد كما
يتحدث يعني جار المنزل المستهدف
ب
وجود عالقين تحت هذا الركان البحث مستمر
من فرق
الانقاظ نحن تحت
ركام
منزل ومنازل يعني مربع سكني
كامل دمرته المقاتلات الحربيه في منطقه
الزوايده